il
c'est bon bon bon
c'est bon bon bon des petites voix qui
s'exerce et découvre le chant depuis
plus d'un mois ce choeur d'enfants
répète une fois par semaine pendant 1h30
et apprend les secrets du rythme et de
la musique j'aime bien quand elle chante
j'aime bien la chance ou et j'aime bien
quand chez les athées j'adore sont faits
depuis tout petit et je prends du
plaisir en chantant on a appris les
prénoms de tout le monde
elles prennent un beau chanter huit
enfants de 6 à 11 ans font aujourd'hui
partie de cette association la petite
fabrique est lancée en 2020 par deux
amis environ
s'aimer d'une envie commune où on et
choristes mais on est aussi maman et le
plaisir que l'on trouve en scène de long
de longue date avec magali ou même dans
des expériences antérieures
quelque chose de communicatif et qu on
avait aussi envie de transmettre
en fait ils ont une partie à la fois de
créativité et à la fois petit actis
synchronise plus fort à la direction
magali l'ange chanteuse depuis l'âge de
11 ans choristes professionnels le chef
de choeur damier les enfants d'abord à
s'ouvrir alors purement d'abord
musicalement va on va interpréter et
écouter on a fait aussi de l' écoute de
musique classique de rock de jazz on
fera des musiques du monde des chansons
dans plusieurs langues mais plus
globalement c'est aussi que l'enfant
s'empare de tous qui sait faire
oralement de son corps
les ateliers de chant choral sont
accompagnés de mise en scène et de
solfège un joli grain ou tout simplement
une envie de chanter la petite fabrique
accepte de nouvelles voies sans audition
d'entrée
on